قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف جالانت
ان يحيى السنوار يسمع دوي القصف الذي
ينفذه سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وقريبا سيرى
فوهات بنادق القوات الاسرائيليه اضاف
جالانت ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل عملياته
في محيط خان يونس وجنوبي قطاع غزه
وسيتحقق اخرى
لاحقا ي السين يحيى السنوار يسمع الان
اصوات ال وجرافات الجيش الاسرائيلي من
فوقه وقنابل سلاح الجو وسوف يلتقي فوهات
بنادقنا قريبا نشاط جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
والجهاز الامني مستمر في شمال قطاع غزه
العمليه تكمل تدريجيا الاهداف التي
حددناها تفكيك كتائب حماس وضرب قدراتها
تحت الارض نحن نعمل ايضا في خان يونس
وجنوب قطاع غزه وسنعمل في اماكن اخرى في
الايام
القادمه هذا هو نق قت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه عن مصدر مطلع ان تفسيرات
اسرائيل بشان رئيس حماس في غزه يحيى
السنوار غير صحيحه وانه ليس منفصلا عن
الواقع بل لديه استراتيجيه منظمه في حال
استمرار الحرب واضاف المصدر ان خطط
السنوار تتضمن سحب قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
من مواقع في اطار وقف اطلاق النار
لاستعاده القياده والسيط
بينما ينوي الاحتفاظ ببعض الرهائن كورقه
مساومه للمستقبل وقال المصدر لهيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان الوسطاء يدركون ان الوقت
ينفد للتوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
وان حماس تستعد لفتره طويله من الحرب اذا
لم يتم التوصل الى
صفقه